[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and i'll show you how
cloud pubs up can help you keep your
services reliably communicating with
each other
cloud pub sub is an asynchronous
messaging service which means it helps
your tools send receive
and filter events or data streams it
gives you durable message storage
scalable in-order message delivery
consistently high availability and
performance at any scale
and pub sub runs in any google cloud
region in the world so you can easily
use it in jakarta
frankfurt or montreal and of course
everywhere else
you also don't have to provision pub sub
it scales global data delivery
automagically from zero to millions of
messages per second
with pub sub data producers don't need
to change anything when the consumers of
their data change
just publish once and let us manage
distribution this lets more of your
services be entirely stateless
you set up pub sub between services or
applications by defining topics
and then subscriptions which allows
services to receive the messages
published on those topics
this means one-to-many communication
gets much simpler
so you can spread batch image analysis
over multiple workers
or send logs from your security system
to archiving processing and analytics
services
or if you've got a steady stream of data
you can use pub sub to stream that data
into bigquery or dataflow for
intelligent processing
pub sub is really handy for notification
when something bad happens so you can
page the right teams if a system or
service goes
down so next time you need a way to
connect multiple services
applications or data sources take a
minute to try out cloud pub sub
learn more at cloud.google.com pub sub
you